welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin with this Democrats holding
2020s first presidential debate tonight
in Iowa where caucus goers will make
their picks in less than three weeks the
debate stage it's all set and it's the
smallest group of candidates just six to
appear in any debate so far
the newest poll in Iowa shows this that
Joe Biden is jumping to a small lead
over his closest competitors he's up
five points from that same poll back in
November now two of those contenders
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren have
been longtime allies but now for the
first time they're going after each
other in public Warren claims that
Sanders told her he did not believe a
woman could win the presidency ed
O'Keefe is in Des Moines the site of
tonight's debate at good morning I think
things are gonna get interesting tonight
how did all this start between Warren
and Sanders yeah we'll see Tony good
morning the feud centers around a
conversation that Sanders and Warren had
in late 2018 the two like-minded New
England liberals are known to be close
buddies in Washington and have had
plenty of opportunity over the past year
to attack each other their campaigns
have declined to do so until now so yes
I'm with Bernie on Medicare for all the
partnership on display at previous
debates might now be a thing of the past
in a statement last night Warren
described how she and Sanders meant
December 2018 to talk about topics
including gender and the presidential
race I thought a woman could win
Warren's statement reads Sanders she
says disagreed Sanders called earlier
reports of his comments ludicrous and
they contradict what he has said
publicly for years in my view a woman
could be elected president of the United
States
tensions first flared over the weekend
when political reported on a Sanders
campaign memo that told volunteers to
say that Warren only appeals to
wealthier voters and won't be able to
expand the base of the Democratic Party
Sanders denied the reports I have never
said a negative word
a friend of mine and Warren shot back I
hope three
reconsiders and turns his different
direction here in Iowa polls continue to
show a close race this is a real toss-up
multiple surveys put former Vice
President Joe Biden Sanders and former
South Bend Indiana mayor Pete Buda judge
in a statistical time those numbers
helped force New Jersey senator Cory
Booker out of the race I can't wait to
get back on the campaign trail the
campaign as hard as I can for whoever is
the eventual nominee Booker also says a
lack of fundraising and the upcoming
impeachment trial factored into his
decision he was one of nearly thirty
candidates in the most diverse and
largest field of candidates ever just a
dozen remain and just six will appear on
stage at the debate tonight Tony all of
them are white and less diverse as we go
and thank you very much
you